hi everybody I am Saran singhda another
Cloud Consultants here at Google Cloud
I'm really excited to share Cloud
spanner with you today in today's video
we will be talking about implementing a
games leaderboard using Cloud spanner we
will be looking at how spanner is
adopted in the gaming vertical and how
to create and run leaderboard
application using spanner as a backend I
will link the codelab in the video
description below so in the video we
will be covering about Cloud spanner and
gaming and creating and running a
leaderboard
so moving on so what is cloud spanner
and where is it used so spanner is a
globally consistent relational database
popular with game developers companies
increasingly rely on a game's back-end
as a service tier that allows them to
unify the player experience across
gaming platforms spanner with its high
uptime unlimited scalability
transactional support and elasticity and
Industry leading five nines of SLA can
quickly respond to unprecedented changes
in the workload and can help scale back
and better
let's move on with the lab I already
have a test project created here once we
have this created let's go ahead and
create a spanner instance so over here
scroll down to spanner and create a
provision instance uh give an instance
name as Cloud spanner a leaderboard
choose Regional and then under regions
uh you could select any but I would
probably stick with the US Central one
you could select any Processing Unit or
nodes so one processing uh so thousand
processing units is equal into one node
so we'll select thousand Processing Unit
click on create this will take I think a
couple of seconds to create yeah so I
think it's already created yes so once
this is created then we will go ahead
and go to the terminal so you can open a
cloud shell here let me increase the
size of the window so that we could see
what's going on so
over here we would uh do a git clone of
the repo that has already tagged in the
description below
now that we have the code repo cloned we
would go to the Java docs folder and we
are spanner leaderboard in here we would
create a codelab folder and CD into the
folder so you would see that we are
under the codelab folder now so now uh
moving on now let's create a basic Java
application uh named leaderboard by
running Maven build
so we would be running the following
command here so this does nothing but
actually creates a maven but it creates
a Java application called leaderboard
so this would take a couple of seconds
yeah
now in the essence of time I already
went ahead and added a spanner Java
boundaries to pom.xml so over here if
you see I the pom.xml you can now see
that there is code for
a cloud spanner so this will actually
help us building the Java application I
also took the liberty and went ahead and
added some custom code into the
apps.java file which is the main file
that has code for creating uh players
and scores table and also there is code
for inserting data into those tables
along with uh having some custom queries
for running leaderboard so let's go
ahead to that folder structure and see
where exactly uh or how exactly the code
looks like so we would go here Source
main Java Google code lab
uh the file name is app.java so if you
see here
um let me scroll down and you can then
see that we do have a code here for
creating players and scores table then
we also have some custom code for
inserting data over here into the
players and scores table and then
similarly if you go down we have some uh
custom code for looking at the
leaderboard for example if you go down
further you could now see that we are so
this is all the code for inserting data
so if you go down here we have queries
so for example these are the queries
which would be selecting player ID
player names codes timestamp and then we
could obviously run it with the uh the
last week within the last one month or a
year and I'll show you as we move
forward so moving on so now let's do a
maven build of the package so that we
could run the application so over here
after we added pom.xml make sure that
you are in the folder which two has on
that XML file yes so now we would do
Maven package
so this would take a couple of seconds
or I think a minute or so and then you
would be able to see the new package
generated and then once this is done we
would see how exactly the leaderboard
app looks like
okay so over here we are almost done yes
so now we would run java.target
leaderboard.jar so now you can see all
the options here so for example you can
have an option for creating instance uh
the player tables course table inserting
data and so now let's go ahead and
create a leaderboard in here database so
so this should take a
few seconds and it should return
successful which means we would be then
good to go with the leaderboard
database yes
now that we have successfully created
the database and players and scores
table we would go ahead and add data to
players and scores tables so we would go
ahead and run the command here on the
screen and then similarly I would also
run it for the scores table so this
would take a few minutes probably so the
players is done now we would be running
the same for the scores table and once
this is done we would then go ahead and
start looking at the leaderboard
now let's go ahead and start looking at
how the leaderboard would look like so
for example if I was to look at the top
10 players of the year so I would do
something like this and I would pass in
8760 which is the number of hours in a
year so if you hit enter you would see
the top players for the year so over
here you can see the player ID player
name the score and the timestamp so
similarly if I was to look at the top 10
players of the month I would do it uh
like this where 730 is the number of
hours in a month and then similarly I
would do same to see the number of
players top 10 players of the week so
for that I'll do 168.
so you will now see the number of top
the top 10 players of a week
so we just successfully created a
leaderboard application with spanner as
a backend please try the Hands-On lab in
the description below you can learn more
about spanner on the tagged Link in the
video description thank you